[Música]
un fenómeno meteorológico que se vuelve
un espectáculo único en la vida una nube
rica en colores en haikou ciudad del sur
de china esta milagrosa nube arcoiris
apareció con matices y discentes que
hicieron brillar el cielo filmada la
semana pasada la vibrante nube no tardó
en hacerse viral en las redes sociales
con internautas asombrados por el
espectáculo
pero la formación de una nube como ésta
es compleja conocida como nuevo banda o
videos se forma primero por el
enfriamiento y la condensación del aire
húmedo forzado sobre el pico
cuando el sol se encuentra en el ángulo
adecuado con rayos entre 10 y 40 grados
centígrados la luz se disfraza entre las
gotas y los cristales de hielo de la
nube creando los colores del arco iris
cuando los observamos es muy por encima
del horizonte ocurre normalmente al
principio o al final del día cuando la
posición relativa del sol la nube y el
observador nos permite verlo luca las
nubes bufanda y la licencia de las nubes
se ven más a menudo en asia con el clima
es más favorable como aquí en japón este
verano donde los cielos se iluminaron en
el horizonte o incluso a veces pueden
ser más discretas como en este vídeo de